what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
story lines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this
channel so a lot of you guys really
really seem to enjoy the whole idea of
uh answering the question how powerful
is Legion the age of X story they gave
us a scenario where one of Legions
personalities basically went crazy and
then turned really just kind of altered
reality you know took this little Island
Utopia that the X-Men had been residing
on Warped the very fabric of existence
to the point that this island was
basically turned into kind of like a
fortress and then took everything else
in the universe and put it inside of a
box it basically removed uh this this
island this Fortress from all of
existence and it was crazy because it's
this mindboggling Display of Power and
so what I thought we would do for the
next you know couple weeks or so is we
would basically follow up with lost
Legions now what lost Legions does is it
immediately comes out of age of X in the
sense that once reality was restored to
normal at the end of the video that we
did last week which you'll find down in
the description uh what we ended up
finding out was that a few of legion's
personalities had basically taken off
now the way this worked was actually
kind of interesting somewhere along the
line remember Dr Nemesis was the guy who
was working alongside Charles Xavier to
try to mend the mind to try to delete
these personalities of Legion somewhere
along the line after the events of age
of X Dr Nemesis had provided Legion with
a neural switchboard and what this meant
was that Legion could basically tap into
the powers of his personalities and that
was a really cool concept because this
has never really happened before
remember when it comes to the character
of Legion he has thousands of
personalities like over a thousand
Personalities in his mind and each
personality has a distinctive power and
so the character of Cindy for example
who can control fire will manifest it'll
you know Cindy will take over the body
of Legion Cindy will be the active
personality and then she'll just begin
using you know pyrokinesis to do
whatever it is that she wants to do but
Legion David holler himself could not
access her abilities on his own what
this neural switchboard does is it
allows David holler to access these
powers while keeping his mind intact and
so essentially what this does is it
makes him quite possibly the most
powerful mutant in existence well beyond
the powers of Matthew Maloy and that's
kind of the difference here and this is
something that I wanted to talk about
because a lot of people have asked this
question when it comes to individuals
whose minds are whole that is to say
they have no multiple personalities and
it's just them and whatever power they
happen to have Matthew Malloy is right
up there at the cream of the crop the
reason why Legion is so powerful is
because he has thousands of powers a
multitude of different powers and so
that's what makes him so capable really
up until lost Legions uh Legion himself
David holler was just like this wildly
powerful individual but you never knew
what his story was going to be about you
never knew what what things were going
to do but the fact remains here that
when Legion began using this neural
switchboard and began accessing these
various personalities and testing these
powers out what we found was that six
personalities had basically come up
missing now these six personalities come
in the form of ingame Susan and sunshine
chain time sync the bleeding image and
sticks now Susan and sunshine was always
my favorite
personality more than Jam Kamari more
than like Jack Wayne you know she was
always one of my favorite characters
because she's like a little girl
basically but what we find out here is
that when the age of X timeline with
that series of events had taken place
that all of legion's personalities had
physical bodies the problem is that when
David holler had seized control of his
mind again and he had set everything
back to normal these six personalities
did not go back into the mind of Legion
instead they basically manifested out in
the real world and that's essentially
what everybody's beginning to understand
now the way that we learn this the way
that it's verified is by way of Rogue
now this is something that I want to
touch on here for a second historically
speaking rogue's character was always a
mutant that she would basically just
absorb people's life Essence their
memories their powers by by physical
touch and it was a passive ability
meaning she could not control it and
whenever she touched someone if she held
on long enough she would basically kill
them the issue with this is that Marvel
had been writing you know Rogue for
decades and so the idea was to basically
revamp her character to change her up
not only that the X-Men Mythos kind of
needed to be changed up a bit and so of
course we saw the House of M story line
which reduced the mutant population down
to 198 this was a multi-stage to effort
the next stage was to go through each of
these individual mutants and start to
change them go through some of the X-Men
and alter their past alter their
characters what they were about how they
focused different things like that
that's the reason why in this story and
we'll get to that here in a second
Cyclops is basically leading the X-Men
because after the events of House of M
Xavier was missing and so it was left to
Cyclops and Emma Frost to run the Xavier
school for gifted youngsters when
Charles came back he basically kind of
had to acques and let them continue
running the show and so he was more of
an adviser than an actual leader of the
X-Men at the time but with the character
of Rogue what had happened is there was
basically this bomb more or less this
kind of you know wildly powerful bomb
that was uh I guess created or
controlled by the Shar called the
hecaton and inside this hecaton were
just like Memories personalities a
multitude of things where the bomb had
basically been detonated and all these
personalities had been absorbed by Rogue
the issue was that she had billions of
personalities in her mind and it
basically began to overwhelm her now all
this came to a head during the events of
Messiah complex when the first mutant
Hope Summers was born after the events
of mday of of the House of M and what
had happened was Hope Summers her hand
had basically been touched to Rogue Hope
was not impacted by rogue's deadly touch
and the result was that all the
Personalities in rogue's mind were
basically wiped clean it was essentially
a soft reboot for her character and so
going forward after that the only
personality in rogue's mind was her own
as well as the personality of Mystique
who she basically lashed out at because
Mystique was the one that put the Hand
of Hope Summers to you know to to
rogue's face but what ended up happening
is Marvel had a story called X-Men Sal
X-Men Legacy Salvage and all that did
was just kind of like see The Return of
Rogue to the uh to the X-Men roster
among other things but during this time
Rogue had basically learn to control her
power so she can touch anybody it
doesn't mean she's going to absorb their
personalities or powers or anything like
that she can touch anyone she wants to
she now has the freedom to control her
abilities and it was actually a great
change for her character because after a
while everybody got tired of hearing
Rogue cry about how she couldn't touch
another human being you know sorry about
your luck Rog get over it so what ended
up happening or at least what we do here
anyway is we transition over to Cyclops
now of course the idea here is that as
as far as everybody's aware these
personalities are hiding out in Europe
as well as London and so the idea is to
basically take a team of Gambit who can
track them down Rogue who can act as
this sort of telepath to a degree by
helping to tap into the mind of of
Legion through physical touch Charles
Xavier who can be a tried and true
telepath as well as Legion himself and
the four of them intend to basically
track down each of these personalities
capturing them allowing Legion to
basically absorb them into himself now
the caveat to this is that Magneto is
basically brought on board by Cyclops as
well as a girl named frenzy now frenzy
is not wildly important for this
particular video but frenzy is basically
a girl that has indestructible skin the
only thing that can penetrate her skin
is adamantium in addition to this this
durability that she has is also extends
to internal organs and that's like the
difference between frenzy and Luke Cage
right I mean if you were to take Luke
Cage and you dropped him out of a you
know out of an airplane at 10,000 ft he
would die because of the fact that his
organs would just hit against his skin
his brain would probably smash against
his skull because his internal organs
are not impenetrable it's just his skin
that's impenetrable with frenzy it's not
that way she can withstand virtually
anything she's very incredible hulk-like
in that capacity she's not nearly on the
same strength level as the Incredible
Hulk but in terms of her durability
she's for all intents and purposes
completely indestructible but what this
does is this basically picks up in a
small town with regards to the arrival
of Gambit and Xavier Magneto all these
different guys and they're trying to
track down time scene this is when
things get really really cool the reason
why is because when they get to this
town everybody's not kned out cold now
no one really knows why and even Legion
himself says he doesn't know why and the
reason for this is because of the fact
the time Sync has the ability to
manipulate time he doesn't really have
anything to do with the human mind
outside of how the human mind perceives
time and people's ability to move back
and forth through time and so of course
the cool thing about this is that
because these are not physical beings
because they're not like actually people
they're basically personalities it's
like trying to catch smoke so for
Charles Xavier he can't really read
their mind per se because they're not
really alive they don't really have like
sinaps and different things like that so
it's this crazy situation but ultimately
what ends up happening is between a
combination of Gambit as well as Magneto
eventually finding frenzy where she's
basically Frozen in time after she had
first encountered time sync Magneto is
able to trace him down or able to to
track him down and the cool thing is
that Magneto tries to use like an EMP
like anro electromagnetic pulse to try
to basically knock out time sync or at
least you know disrupt what passes for a
brain functions inside his head the
funny thing about this is that time sync
says when you guys first got here all
the people in this Village were knocked
out the reason why is because when you
Ed your powers to create this EMP I
opened a portal through time I sent that
power into the past and it knocked out
everybody in the town so it's really
cool the way this the way this unfolds
it's actually really really interesting
but you guys see the danger with these
kind of personalities and time thinks
not even the most dangerous one like I
would say sticks is probably the most
dangerous of all the personalities uh
maybe Susan in sunshine because she's
you don't really suspect her to be as
dangerous as she is but the cool thing
about this is that eventually Gambit's
able to track down time sync and that's
what's wild about this is because when
Gambit tries to grab him time sync just
starts manipulating time around him and
forces Gambit to relive these these
crushing moments in his life you know
the experiences of his abusive father
being part of the mutant Massacre or at
least leading the Marauders to the
Morlock tunnels and then bailing out
before the mutant Massacre happened but
basically engineering the possibility
for them to Massacre all the morlocks
below New York that's a that's a really
old story from way back in the day it
was really like the first major X-Men
crossover in Marvel Comics but the fact
remains that that Gambit's taken out
quick fast and in a hurry and So
eventually Legions able to track down
his own personality now that's kind of
the funny thing here is because what
time sync says is we escaped like your
mind is a prison we didn't want to be
housed there anymore and that's why this
whole concept of Legion personalities
work because they think for themselves
they have their own thoughts their own
emotions their own wants their own
desires they are for all intents and
purposes distinctly different
individuals that's why the whole idea of
Legion having multiple personalities was
such a dangerous thing is because when
one of those personalities takes over
the body of of David holler then there's
no telling what it is they might do if
they're a particularly Evil Personality
they'll do terribly evil things if it's
like David holler himself where he just
kind of goes nuts and decides that he
wants to kill Magneto in the past he
does that Xavier jumps in the way and
the Age of Apocalypse starts and so it
creates these really really cool
situations in terms of what stories we
might see but ultimately Legion kind of
proves to be a little bit powerless
towards this personality and that's the
other half of this is that we would
think that with these being the
personalities of David holler himself
all these different aspects you know
these different personalities of his
it'd be easy for him to control them
that he would just be able to grab them
and pull them back in it doesn't work
that way because they have powers and
some of them have powers that Legion
himself cannot directly counter and so
with regards to the character of time
sync his ability to manipulate the very
fabric of time creates for a wildly
dangerous situation because he can
basically freeze time around Legion
freeze all time in existence walk
towards Legion unfreeze time and then
stab him in the back and so it creates
this really really interesting situation
because it shows us what kind of
scenario we would be seeing if mutants
had these particular powers in in the
actual ICS themselves the closest we
come to a lot of these with the
exception of telepath especially when it
comes to something like this for for
time manipulation would be like Thanos
with the time Stone you know when he was
we were doing what when we were going
through The Infinity Gauntlet story line
and he started sending people back to
the age of dinosaurs on the planet Earth
just literally started dropping them
through these different eras in the
universe's history but again really all
Legion was doing here was just buying
time and the reason why was because
despite the fact that time sync is not
really like a person per se time sync is
made up of a substance he's made up of
something and so because of the fact
that he's basically solid matter even
though he's still a personality he's
tangible and if he if he's tangible he
can be touched and if he can be touched
Rogue can steal his powers and that's
exactly what she does she basically
sneaks up on him from behind grabs him
shuts his powers down after stealing
them and then eventually you know time
sync is just a normal human being just a
normal person you know and so what ends
up happening here is Legion basically
just kind of absorbs time sync back into
himself again but he says things are
only going to get more dangerous from
here things are only going to get worse
because we still got Susan and sunshine
that we have to face off against still
got chain that we have to face off
against a person that's that's virtually
Untouchable uh we have stick I'm sorry
sticks that we're ultimately going to
have to face off against probably one of
the most dangerous of all his
personalities and so what we do is we
transition to Sticks proper and what we
find out is that with sticks being a
telepath his telepathy exists in a
multitude of different ways there's
traditional telepathy where he can just
read the mind of people around him but
sticks also has the ability to grab the
mind of a person and then use them as an
anchor to what's going on now the reason
why sticks does this instead of just
like taking over the mind of one of the
people there is because if sticks did
that Charles Xavier would immediately
pick it up and would immediately know
what's going on instead by going through
a person it's basically like a proxy
it's sticks going through this woman and
then no one really knows what's going on
no one's aware that it's happening
instead he can simply just kind of
operate like a fly on the wall listening
to this conversation that's going on and
in turn have an understanding of what
the team of Charles Xavier and Magneto
are intending to do with regards to
capturing and rounding up these
different personalities with the group
more or less taking off to London which
is where these personalities were last
believed to be the issue with this is
that Professor X is kind of helping to
guide them to a degree but the problem
is that as they make their way through
this they're immediately met by chain
and the reason why is because they get
into this town and everyone's gone like
everybody's basically vanished now with
the personality of chain he basically
has self- duplication but he's not like
Jamie madro he's not like you know
multiple men Jamie Madrox just makes
duplicates of himself uh but you can
destroy any of the duplicates and it
doesn't matter with chain it's a lot of
the same way the difference is that he
duplicates by touching so if he touches
you you become a duplicate of him now if
you kill the original chain well then
everybody else just go back to normal
it's kind of the writer's way out it's
Marvel's way out of this story without
sacrificing an entire town of people in
England but the idea here is that all
the personalities can think
independently but they also share hive
mind at the same time that makes any
sense you know for example the 1A you
know uh chain 1A is like the main
personality the main individual that all
these others branched off from chain 1A
has his own own Ambitions his own goals
he's working alongside stick in order to
stay out of the mind of Legion to keep
from being captured all the other
personalities follow his orders but they
can also think for themselves so I guess
maybe they could Rebel if they wanted to
but they wouldn't really have a reason
to but the cool thing here is that again
chain himself that's his only real real
ability he doesn't have like energy
projection or anything but he has all
kinds of weapons and that's the problem
is when they get in here they're facing
an army of thousands of people all of
whom have weapons and so it creates this
wildly insane situation of course for
the for the most part the X-Men are able
to hold their own to a degree I mean you
know Magneto Rogue these folks are able
to hold their own and they they serve
their purpose of course the issue here
is that eventually Legion jumps back
into The Fray and legion's able to
absorb chain back into himself uh quick
fast and in a hurry but in the middle of
all this what ends up happening is that
the mission turns out to be a success in
the sense that this was all designed to
be a distraction this was all designed
to be a ruse the overarching goal of
chain was to serve the purpose of
basically having everybody look over
here so that he could have one of his
personalities kidnap Charles Xavier and
take him over to Sticks now
transitioning over to Gambit and friend
remember Gambit just kind of being this
swaave guy that everybody loves it's
kind of a hold over from the 1990s uh
and frenzy being a character that dates
back quite some time and actually served
as one of the Agents of Apocalypse the
two of them don't really see eye to eye
and they never have a lot of this is
because of the fact that frenzy just
doesn't trust anyone like frenzy is very
Magneto esque in her in terms of her
personality in terms of the fact that
she doesn't really like people she views
Humanity normal humans Baseline humans
as being evil in a lot of different ways
but in the midst of their conversation
suddenly both frenzy and Gambit start
kissing another now as soon as that
happens they're like what the heck is
going on here and that's when they start
to realize it's mind control and that's
what Susan and sunshine does she doesn't
really control minds she amplifies
emotions and that's kind of what's being
hinted at here is that the Baseline
emotion between the two of these people
between Gambit and frenzy is some
measure of Attraction that's there the
issue is that they would never act on it
because their ideals are are two totally
different things they would never really
see eye to eye but Susan and Sunshine's
able to grab that emotion and bring it
out now the caveat to this is that Susan
and Sunshine's powers are directly tied
to her emotional state and that's the
crushing thing because they were like we
have to go like when Legion was
explaining who Susan and sunshine was
they were like we have to go to London
and we have to like bate a little girl
like really like we have to make a
little girl cry like how evil is that
and it's hilarious it's funny to see it
happen but of course uh you know Susan
and sunshine again just kind of meanders
to herself you just kind of amuses to
herself about how happy she is but
ultimately frenzy just like rips the
head off her dolly and makes Susan and
sunshine cry and that's when her power
begins to dissipate that's when her
power begins to go away now of course we
only get a quick Glimpse keep in mind
Susan and sunshine is the personality of
a little girl and she thinks and feels
like a little girl and so really all she
wants to do is go home and so when
Legion approaches you know she's like
yay I can finally go back home because
these are one of the personalities that
escaped but didn't really follow stix's
lead didn't really believe in what sxs
was doing she was just kind of out there
in left field doing her own thing you
know manipulating people's emotions and
and kind of making them go crazy but of
course she ends up merging back with uh
with Legion again but the cool thing
about this is that legion's able to to
eventually track down chain one a and of
course you know again once chain 1A is
reabsorbed the question is if Charles
Xavier's missing then the only person
that would have taken him would have
been sticks and if he's been taken to
Sticks then that presents the most
dangerous scenario and this is when we
start to learn a little bit about
sticks' Powers what it is that he's
capable of the problem is that as they
continue as they go through their
journey and they eventually end up in
Paris which is where sticks is residing
and they end up having to go down into
the catacombs Rogue comes across
bleeding image now bleeding image is
another one of these really really cool
personalities because bleeding image is
basically a voodoo doll if bleeding
image comes across you and he basically
you know kind of imprints on you he can
begin stabbing himself in different
locations or inflicting harm on himself
and you'll feel the pain instead of him
and it's it's cool in terms of how that
happens because it's a great counter to
the character of Rogue if Rogue can like
touch somebody and absorb their powers
well then what do you do like where do
you go from there like how do you get
that to work how do you square that
Circle and so the funny thing about this
is that uh is that what bleeding image
does is essentially say look the powers
of Rogue because of the fact that
bleeding image is one of legion's
personalities and bleeding image knows
everything Legion knows which means
bleeding image knows how the X-Men
function one of the things that he does
he says okay look I can't defeat Rogue
through conventional means I mean I can
cause her physical pain but I'm here to
serve as a distraction I'm here to allow
sticks to make sure he can carry out his
plan and so what he does is he basically
blows himself up now this annihilates
the bleeding image personality right
like that personality is totally
destroyed gone forever but the purpose
was served the purpose was to
incapacitate Rogue now on the surface we
would look at this and we would say well
I mean Rogue is virtually impervious to
physical harm right well she is to a
degree I mean an explosion that close of
that magnitude would cause an issue for
virtually anybody aside from like the
Incredible Hulk or Juggernaut or
apocalypse or somebody like that but
because of the fact that bleeding image
imprints his pain on others the pain
that bleeding image felt with the
explosion is Amplified in the mind of
Rogue and so it basically sends her
nervous system into complete and total
shock now the other half of this is
trying to find Charles Xavier and that's
the crazy thing is because throughout
all of this legion's been using the time
sync power in order to keep Time Frozen
in Paris the ISS issue is that the more
Legion uses these Powers the more
prominent the personalities become and
so it's basically time sync fighting
back against Legion and trying to break
itself free so you guys kind of see how
these personalities are very
self-contained how they operate in and
of themselves but also how they have
their own desires and wants and
Ambitions to get away now the whole idea
of housing these personalities actually
comes into play you know really big time
with uh X-Men Legacy Legion for those of
you guys who watch the legion TV show
the concept of the insane asylum housing
these personalities is basically a stand
in for the prison that Legion makes in
his mind for all the Personalities in
the X-Men Legacy Legion comic but what
they end up doing is they basically come
to this realization that the only way to
really defeat sticks is to essentially
allow Legion to relinquish his control
over time to basically walk away with
his control over time and in turn allow
sticks to continue on with his own
individual plan now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that
where're Legion froze time because of
the fact that the personalities he has
are part and partial to to Legion
himself those personalities weren't
Frozen those personalities were continue
were able to continue operating the
issue is everyone around those
personalities was frozen and so
basically sticks couldn't really
continue his plan it gave them the
ability to buy time but in the end it
didn't really matter because of the fact
that when it came to the characters of
the X-Men uh they still had to find sxs
himself and sxs could still could still
carry out his own campaign of course we
see this campaign coming to fruition
when the X-Men descend down into the
catacombs of Paris now when they get
there all they're seeing are Illusions I
mean normally the catacombs just lead
below a church but they're basically
seeing what amounts to hell all these
individuals whose Souls have been taken
and who are writhing and screaming in
pain it looks very much like the uh the
The Nine Circles of Hell in uh in
Dante's Divine poem Inferno I think is
what it was called it creates a really
cool interesting situation here but what
what sticks is also done is he's
basically dressed up skeletons to look
like members of the X-Men and so it's
just playing mind games right I mean
it's playing mind games it's playing
Shadow games it's basically you know
screwing with their heads leading them
to believe that what they're seeing is
real but then blurring the lines between
what's real and what's not real now the
other half of this is that because SX
knows the X-Men so well as a personality
of Legion s is also aware of the fact
that the X-Men will not kill if they
don't have to and so what what sticks
basically does is say look I have
Charles Xavier that's how I'm casting
all these Illusions in the first place
what sticks does is take all these
different individuals whose Souls that
he's absorbed and he sends them towards
the X-Men now that's the inherent power
of sticks sticks basically goes to
individuals touches them absorbs their
souls their souls live on in him and
then he has total control of their
physical body so you know in a lot of
ways sticks is very much this demon
personality the funny thing about this
though is that Legion essentially walks
away and ends up traveling to sticks and
the reason why is because Legion says
I'm the one you want like you're chasing
after me for a reason what's the reason
that you want me for leave the other
X-Men alone and when when basically
Legion hands himself over to Sticks Stix
says this has always been my goal my
goal has basically to has been to grab
the mor mcag personality from age of X
the personality that has the ability to
warp reality on a universal level I want
to have that personality I want to have
that power and I want to recreate all of
existence for myself the funny thing is
that once sticks grabs that personality
or at least grabs the uh the body of
legion what ends up happening is SS
grabs the personality of endgame now
endgame again is one of these these own
you know Concepts in the realm of Legion
that exists for self-preservation the
kicker here is that ingame has what's
called an Adaptive metamorphosis in the
sense that ingame can adapt to whatever
it is that's attacking him now we see
that play out in a few different ways of
course you've got the super strength the
frenzy you know she starts throwing
objects at it the uh the durability of
endgame enhances in order to withstand
the various objects that is throwing at
her but because of the fact that ingame
is basically just a giant robot is how
it manifests Magneto turns and says only
a fool would send a robot against me
well in response in game it basically
changes itself up to where it's not a
metallic form anymore that's how ingame
functions it's able to adapt to
virtually any situation is very much
like Darwin from the uh X-Men deadly
Genesis storyline so it's really cool in
terms of how uh how ingame works but
then we find out the ruse that was
created here by uh by Legion himself and
what I mean here is that it seemed like
Legion was giving up right like he was
basically just kind of like giving in to
sticks and saying okay it poses a
dangerous situation if if Legion gave
over to sticks that means that sticks
would have access to all the powers that
Legion possesses and it's like well then
there's thousands of powers that range
anywhere from you know Baseline
telepathy all the way up to reality on a
universal scale well then it was it
would be the end of all things like it
would be the end of everything but we
find out what had happened is that this
Legion personality that SS has been
talking to is not the actual Legion
instead Legion was using the powers of
chain to duplicate himself and that what
had happened was that when this
personality I'm sorry when when Legion
himself basically entered or at least it
seemed like he entered the mind of
sticks this personality is actually
Rogue or at least this person is
actually Rogue that Legion imprinted
himself on he basically gave up his
powers where he he let Rogue go back to
who she was before and then she turns
around and ab starts absorbing the
energy of uh of sticks now what this
does is it begins to sort of lock them
in this psychic knot in the sense that
you basically have Legion having to
absorb both Rogue and uh and sticks at
the same time in order to keep sticks
confined and so what ends up happening
here is that Charles Xavier actually has
to delve into the mind of Legion in
order to basically sort out this this
psychic knot that exists between sticks
and Rog and this is cool because we get
a small glimpse of a lot of these
personalities and how they exist in the
mind of Legion for example they're all
basically kind of shattered they're in
pieces they're just scattered to the
wind it's like a 15-year-old kid's
bedroom stuffs just everywhere his mind
is in total chaos and that was always
the struggle of Legion that was always
the issue with this character was that
there was no organization to his mind
there was no there was no structure
there was no form there was no basis it
was all just crazy the personalties are
just kind of running they were all doing
whatever it was that they wanted to do
that'll be the basis behind the whole
X-Men Legacy Legion Persona it'll be
basically him you know where his
personality is escape from their cells
so to speak in his mind and he has to
start going around and rounding them up
now there is also a whole another story
that kind of gets tied in as a second
half but what is up happening of course
is that Xavier is able to basically
untie this psychic knot and in response
to that all these personalities are
confined back again within the mind of
Legion but what this does is it starts
to kind of go out into the secondary
plotline that uh that was being written
for the story with regards to the the
capture of like Rachel gray you know and
some of these other characters by the sh
that's not really relevant to our
discussion here at hand our little
section just pretty much wraps up with
the idea that uh that Legion was able to
to regain his different personalities
but again this is a pretty short little
segment again it's not super lengthy
it's not really long I just thought it'd
be kind of a fun little story where we
did a bit of a tour about the different
personalities of Legion how they
function how they come together that
kind of thing but um if you guys are new
here to com exp explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the robore if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
this is this is really kind of
interesting again uh X-Men Legacy Legion
really focuses a lot on his character we
see a lot of other cool personalities
like the oramus the oramus is awesome we
get to see a lot of these really cool
interesting Concepts um I can't remember
the name of the guy but he's like this
weird giant green octopus thing that has
the power of of telepathy like Omega
Level telepathy it's crazy you know the
kind of things that that Legion can do
but uh yeah we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
this